ALSO CAMPAIGN FINANCE REFORM AND
ALSO SAY HE TOOK A MILLION
DOLLARS FROM RUSSIA AND DIDN’T
WANT TO REPORTED.
HERE WITH REACTION,
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
BY THE WAY, THERE’S A NIGHTLY
PODCAST, CALLED VERDICT.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, A LIBERAL, SAYS
YOU WERE ONE OF HIS BEST
STUDENTS EVER AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL.
LET’S GO OVER WHAT I HAVE JUST
DISCUSS.
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH MY ANALYSIS
AND PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ’S
ANALYSIS?
>> I DO.
I THINK PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ’S
ARGUMENT THAT HE PRESENTED TO
THIS END IT WAS POWERFUL AND
COMPELLING.
THAT THE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES
HIGH CRIMES OR MISDEMEANORS,
THAT THE TEST FOR IMPEACHMENT IS
TREASON, BRIBERY OR OTHER HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS.
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS, THEY
HAVEN’T ALLEGED ANY CRIME
WHATSOEVER.
IT UTTERLY FAILS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARD.
BUT SEAN, I LISTEN TO YOUR
OPENING MONOLOGUE AND THE FOUR
AND FIVE POINTS THAT YOU MADE
AND THEY ARE RIGHT.
BUT LET ME BOIL IT DOWN TO ONE.
ONE POINT THAT EXPLAINS WHY THE
PRESIDENT IS INNOCENT AND HE
SHOULD BE ACQUITTED AND WHY HE
WILL BE ACQUITTED.
QUID PRO QUO DOESN’T MATTER.
IT’S A RED HERRING.
IT DOESN’T MATTER IF THERE WAS A
QUID PRO QUO OR NOT.
THE REASON IS, A PRESIDENT IS
ALWAYS JUSTIFIED AND IN FACT HAS
A RESPONSIBILITY TO INVESTIGATE
CREDIBLE EVIDENCE OF CORRUPTION.
THE DEMOCRATS BUILT THEIR ENTIRE
CASE ON THE PROPOSITION THAT IT
WAS BASELESS AND A SHAM AND
PHONY TO INVESTIGATE CORRUPTION,
TO INVESTIGATE BURISMA AND THE
BIDENS.
YOU HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB OF
WALKING THROUGH THE REALITY
WHICH IS, THERE WAS A MOUNTAIN
OF EVIDENCE.
DO I KNOW FOR A FACT JOE BIDEN
WAS CORRUPT?
NO.
BUT THERE WAS MORE THAN ENOUGH
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO SAY WE
OUGHT TO INVESTIGATE HIM, WHEN
THIS GUY’S SON IS GETTING PAID A
MILLION BUCKS A YEAR, WHEN HE’S
BRAGGING ABOUT FORCING UKRAINE
TO FIRE THE PROSECUTOR.
THAT STINKS AND A MINIMUM SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATED.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF.
>> Sean: SENATOR , I HAVE BEEN
SAYING THAT IT’S THE PRESIDENT’S
ROLE TO FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE
LAWS OF THE LAND.
A UKRAINE COURT, POLITICO,
JANUARY 11, 2017, THEY LAID OUT
CHAPTER AND VERSE THAT UKRAINE,
SEPARATE AND APART FROM THE
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE THAT DID
OCCUR, THAT THEY INTERFERED IN
OUR ELECTION.
CAN YOU DO US A FAVOR, GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT?
WE SPENT THREE YEARS DEALING
WITH IT.
NUMBER TWO, OKAY, JOE BIDEN ON
TAPE.
YOU’RE NOT GETTING THE BILLION?
UNTIL YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO EXPERIENCE
SON, GOING TO CONTINUE TO GET
PAID.
I AM NOT A LAWYER, TED CRUZ.
YOU ARE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE NOT ONLY
FAITHFULLY EXECUTING BUT I THINK
EVEN SEAN HANNITY CAN BRING THAT
BEFORE A JURY AND GET A
CONVICTION.
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT’S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATS’
ARGUMENT AND THEY WILL SAY THE
SENATE, WE HAVE CONDUCTED A FAIR
TRIAL.
WE LISTENED TO THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS FOR 22 HOURS.
WE LISTENED UNTIL PRACTICALLY
OUR EARS BLED.
WE HEARD ALL THE EVIDENCE,
ALTHOUGH WITNESS TESTIMONY,
EVERY ARGUMENT THAT THEY MADE
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
YOU KNOW, THEY SPENT ABOUT HALF
THAT TIME TRYING TO PROVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO JOE BIDEN,
HUNTER BIDEN, AND BURISMA.
YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU AND I
COULD’VE PROVE THAT IN 30
SECONDS BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
HAS SET IT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION REPEATEDLY.
THAT IS CONCEDED, YES.
DONALD TRUMP WANTED THE
CORRUPTION OR POTENTIAL
CORRUPTION INVESTIGATED.
THAT’S A GOOD THING, NOT A BAD
THING.
I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING ELSE
THAT’S IRONIC.
EVERYTHING THEY ACCUSED THE
PRESIDENT UP AND SAY THE
PRESIDENT DID WRONG, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE WORSE.
SO THEY ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT OF
WITHHOLDING AID TO UKRAINE.
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT
BARACK OBAMA REFUSED TO GIVE
LEGAL AID TO UKRAINE FOR HIS
ENTIRE PRESIDENCY.
DONALD TRUMP HAS GIVEN JAVELIN
MISSILES, ANTITANK MISSILES.
IF DELAYING AID TO UKRAINE IS
WRONG, THAN OBAMA DID IT WORSE.
IF THE INVESTIGATING A POLITICAL
RIVAL IS WRONG, THEN LET’S PAUSE
INVESTIGATED A POLITICAL RIVAL,
SENTENCE FIVE, SENT IN WIRETAPS,
UNLEASH THE FBI AND DOJ AND
INVESTIGATED THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE.
THE DEMOCRATS, IT’S WORTH ASKING
THEM, WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU
SAYING THE PRESIDENT DID WRONG
AND WHICH PART OF IT HAS YOUR
PARTY NOT DONE TENFOLD WORSE?
>> Sean: WELL SAID, SENATOR.
I’LL TELL YOU ANOTHER THING.
I AM THANKFUL THE PRESIDENT IS
LOOKING OUT FOR OUR MONEY.
YOU ARE HANGING OUT WITH THOSE
SAME GUYS AS YOUR PREDECESSOR,
THAT’S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
NEVER MENTIONED THE AID.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
I WANT NOTHING.
AND AT THE END, FOUR FACTS
REMAIN THE SAME.
FIVE SUBSEQUENT MEETINGS,
HIGH-PROFILE WITH ZELENSKY, AID
NEVER DISCUSSED, SENATOR CRUZ.
THIS NEEDS TO END AND IF YOU’RE
CALLING ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
DON’T END IT, THAN I’VE GOT A
PROBLEM WITH ALL OF THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE USELESS TO OUR
CONSTITUTION AND THE RULE OF LAW
IN MY OPINION.
>> LOOK, I AGREE.
ENOUGH ALREADY.
MOVE ON.
ON FRIDAY, I’M GOING TO VOTE
THAT WE DON’T NEED ANYMORE
WITNESSES WITH 17 WITNESSES IN
THE HOUSE, WE’VE HEARD ALL THE
EVIDENCE.
THE HOUSE MANAGERS HAVE FAILED.
I HOPE THAT MOTION PASSES.
IT’S CLOSE.
ALL 47 DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
VOTE FOR MORE WITNESSES BECAUSE
THEY WANT A FISHING EXPEDITION.
WE MAY GET -- I HOPE WE DON’T
BUT WE MIGHT GET FOUR WOBBLY
REPUBLICAN STANDING WITH THEM.
YOU MENTIONED A FEW MINUTES AGO,
THE PODCAST I’M DOING.
I STARTED ON THE FIRST DAY OF
THE TRIAL AND EVERY DAY WHEN THE
TRIAL IS OVER, I JUMP IN A
TRUCK, HEAD TO THE STUDIO AND
RECORD A PODCAST THAT NIGHT.
THE FIRST ONE I DID AT 2:46 IN
THE MORNING AND I SHARE MY
THOUGHTS.
THAT PODCAST WENT FROM BEING
NONEXISTENT TO BEING THE NUMBER
ONE PODCAST IN THE COUNTRY, THE
NUMBER ONE TOP-RANKED PODCAST
AND IT’S THE VERDICT WITH
TED CRUZ.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FACTS.
>> Sean: I WILL PUT IT UP ON